après le pangolin soi disant
responsables du coronavirus le singe
pourrait-il relancer la variole c'est
vrai que l'om est feinte et roche aurait
une récente multiplication des cas en
europe depuis début mai l oms alerte sur
plusieurs cas découverts au royaume uni
en espagne au portugal et au canada plus
d'une cinquantaine de cas de variole du
singe à travers le monde ont déjà été
recensés ça peut quand même tué entre 1
à 10% des malades mais quels sont les
symptômes de cette maladie comment se
transmet tel la variole du singe
proviendrait d'afrique de l'ouest et ne
connaîtraient aucun traitement pour le
moment alors où l'épidémie du
coronavirus diminue cette nouvelle
maladie pourrait vite devenir
préoccupante
alors faut-il s'inquiéter de la variole
du singe qui se développe dans le monde
entier
les chéris je veux remercier bruno
megaman de venir nous voir à chaque fois
l'arrivée à bruno skropeta chef du
service réanimation de l'hôpital
l'hôpital lariboisière je fasse un bruit
c'est beaucoup c'est la première fois
qu'ils voient c'est docteur thierry bedo
ça qui est vétérinaire parce qu'on
voulait avoir un d'été renner voilà qui
nous c'est clair là dessus ce soir parce
que moi c'est le truc qui me fait
flipper actuellement il y avait deux
trucs qui me faisait flipper c'était là
gilles verdez dans l'émission et ça et
non mais c'est vrai que c'est un truc de
fou la variole du singe est une maladie
rare qui se transmet à l'être humain par
les animaux caractérisée par
d'impressionnantes pustules cette
infection se transmet lors de contacts
rapprochés ou des changes de fluides
corporels regarder les photos regarder
ce que ça donne
il ya une infection de l'homme par la
variole du singe se divise en deux
périodes période invasive fièvre à rien
le têt ganglions douleurs musculaires et
période d'éruption que des éruptions
cutanées un visage pour demain plante
des pieds est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter
tout ça c'est vrai que regarde on va
voir d'autres d'autres photos à
regarder
on est fragile a
ses réalités
alors c'est vrai que c'est un truc de
fou cette affaire c'est moi d'abord
parlé à thierry edot ça commence
transmis ce virus peut l'enlever
maintenant cup en fait je vais russie se
transmet par les flots les liquides les
fluides donc par exemple
lorsque le singe qui est dans sa forêt
éternue ou tousse ou se déchirent une
pustule sur une branche et que quelques
minutes plus tard un humain passe par là
eh ben la contamination elle peut
survenir c'est incroyable hélas
aujourd'hui qu'est c'est quoi un animal
sauvage c'est des animaux sauvages donc
là c'est vraiment qu'il ya un humain qui
passe c'est sa pensée ce via l'antenne
locale on se dit ouais ça yens 44,5 à -6
à la pourquoi il ya plus de chance
maintenant de la voir qu'avant en fait
c'est lié là et on l'a on bascule
directement dans une problématique
environnementale
c'est lié à la fragmentation des
habitats sauvages et il ya plus de
contacts aujourd'hui comme on l'a vu
avec le locaux vides hélas il ya plus de
contacts aujourd'hui entre les
populations d'animaux sauvages et les
populations d'humains d'accord et donc
le premier accident avec la
contamination par la variole simienne il
s'est produit avec des singes de
laboratoire au danemark au début des
années 60 donc il y à des conditions
naturelles de propagation et de
contagiosité éventuelle mais c'est très
très rare à ce jour et il y a aussi des
conditions qui sont favorisées par
l'environnement du laboratoire et de
l'expérimentation animale alors est-ce
que
animaux de compagnie peuvent la voir et
peuvent nous transmettre pas du tout à
ce jour je n'ai aucune info qui me
permettrait de pan de vous dire que les
chiens les chats sont des vecteurs de
2,2 de ce virus et risque de le
transmettre à l'homme en revanche il ya
eu par exemple une
une épidémie mais très circonscrites de
variole simienne chez des humains aux
états unis en 2003 et à l'époque c'était
parce que des rats géants qui venait de
gambie avait été vendu aux états unis
comme animaux de compagnie thé ça se
tient le procès des régions devant 2002
et que des écureuils à l'électorat et
les singes regardez donc ça voilà
l'erreur agir
sauve des vies comme on est entraînés
pour détecter les mines en afrique qui
sauve beaucoup de vies ah oui soyons pas
d'envoyer les crs oui on l'a on a plein
de questions à vous poser un jeu suit là
il ya plein de questions qui tombe
actuellement sur les réseaux wi matrice
fait-il qu'ils aient eu autant de cas
dans les pays différents en même temps
pour le moment il ya juste eu je crois
quelques dizaines de cas en europe et
dans au sud de l'europe au portugal et
en espagne états-unis au canada on met
pas mais pas au même moment pas
forcément même moment et après c'est lié
au fait que on passe notre vie a côtoyé
des animaux les animaux de la faune
domestique mais aussi dans certaines
circonstances comme par exemple quand il
ya eu la mode des rats géants de gambie
vendu comme animaux de compagnie aux
états unis il ya aussi un autre rongeurs
qui est potentiels vecteurs c'est le
chien de prairie sa vente est interdite
en france depuis des années mais aux
états unis c'est très populaire de
l'avoir comme animal de compagnie
maintenant alors
laon comme si ça venait d'arriver du
coup si vous dites que ça fait un moment
parce que alors là on va faire stresser
tout le monde l oms a déclaré et là je
vais passer la parole à plus experts que
moi mais l' oms a réussi à éradiquer la
variole chez l'homme
en
1981 et à partir de ce moment là la
variole et la maladie qui chez l'homme a
causé des des désastres encore plus que
la ps je pense mais c'était il ya très
longtemps et le lot et metz a déclaré la
variole disparus a déclaré la
l'éradication de la variole chez l'homme
en 1981 et donc de plus on ne vaccine
que les populations
mais là il s'agit pas du même virus
c'est le virus du singe et chez l'homme
ils causent des formes beaucoup fait
vous êtes en train de dire que c'est
pour nous vacciner contre la variole
alors jeunes jamais j'aurais pensé une
chose pareille mais peut-être que vous
êtes moins naïve que moi alors non mais
c'est vrai que là on va on va rappeler
l'implication de l'animal vers l'homme
contact direct avec du sang des liquides
biologiques des lésions cutanées ou des
muqueuses d'animaux porteurs de la
maladie on à dire les animaux concernés
cinq rats géants de bambi écureuils et
on l'a dit contact étroit avec les
sécrétions respiratoires d'une personne
porteuse de la maladie au contact direct
avec les lésions avec théoule et
l'équipe dans les liquides biologiques
le directeur général adjoint de hermès a
dit nous observons nous observons des
transmissions parmi les hommes ayant des
relations sexuelles avec des hommes ce
qui est nouvelle information que nous
devons étudier a déclaré ibrahima sow
c'est fall directeur général adjoint de
l'om est pour les interventions
d'urgence
l'om est se veut rassurante quand même
si les symptômes semblent virulent le
taux de mortalité reste faible mais on
va en parler dans un instant c'est quand
même une petite galère cette affaire la
durée d'incubation est en général de 6 à
ses jours mais peut aller de 5 à 21
jours la variole du singe n'est pas une
maladie particulièrement dangereuse pour
l'homme mais voilà c'est ce qui est dit
nathalie terre là à l'instant t voilà
les symptômes peuvent durer de 14 à 21
jours et il n'y a pas de traitement
alors ça disparaît tous est ce guide
alors on va on va en parler j'ai un
instant avec avec bruno mais c'est vrai
que il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
questions et c'est vrai que ça commence
à nous arriver parce que l'om est ce
quand l'om s commence à intéresser un
truc c'est que ça commence à ce qu'on
voulait dire un truc rythme oui c'est
bien ça rappelle ce schéma l'animal qui
transmettait sa robe une maladie qui se
propage très contagieux ça rappelle le
corps en un virus est ce qu'il faut
craindre une épidémie mondiale
je ne pense pas mais je ne suis pas
expert dans le domaine mais ceci dit les
il n'y a pas de barrière d'espèce pour
tous les micro organismes pour tous les
microbes que ce soit des virus ou les
bactéries et donc là par exemple
j'espère ne pas héberger trop de mauvais
virus est trop de mauvaises bactéries il
est très exposée la whey et puis moi je
suis un vétérinaire et côtoie tout le
temps des haines de celle ou celui qui a
plus de virus ici c'est lui
[Rires]
il ya aussi autre chose c'est que le
fait d'être exposé à des à des virus qui
sont hébergés par d'autres espèces que
nous peut aussi contribuer à nous
immuniser par exemple sur le co vide
certains pensent que l'exposition aux
coronavirus parce qu'il y a des
coronavirus par exemple chez les chiens
et les chats et nous les vétos et nos
infirmières on est très exposé à ces
coronavirus il est probable que
l'exposition permettent d'aider
résistance à d'autres le virus de la
même famille donc c'est pas toujours un
danger d'être exposés au virus qui est
pathologique pour une autre espèce mais
qu'il est il est très faiblement pour la
nôtre alors on vient de recevoir un info
e1 premier cas suspect de variole du
singe a été recensé en france en région
parisienne ça vient de tomber c'est à
dire là la personne peut-être là
on doit dit on me dit apparemment la
personne fait de la télévision
voilà j'en serais un petit peu plus bas
sur sion la personnel bien entendu mais
sachez qu'à on me dit elle est du côté
gauche
oui merci la renault mégane service
réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière
j'adore cet hôpital et bojador bruno qui
est incroyable à chanel bruno
même question qu'est ce que la variole
du singe donc pour nous les humains
alors c'est une maladie qui touche les
singes et quelques autres espèces
animales comme ça a été dit depuis
longtemps c'est une maladie endémique
dans les forêts tropicales en afrique de
l'ouest et au congo et de temps en temps
il ya des épidémies qui touche les
hommes qui habitent dans la lisière de
la forêt au bord de la forêt alors de
façon exceptionnelle il ya eu des cas à
l'extérieur du continent africain comme
ça a été expliquée
essentiellement lié à des animaux qui
ont été vendus en europe ou aux états
unis ce qui est aujourd'hui un peu plus
différent c'est que pour la première
fois en europe du moins il y à des cas
de contamination interhumaine c'est ça
c'est à dire en fait c'est un singe ou
des animaux qui sont sortis d'afrique
qui ont été mis en europe qui ont
infecté les différentes personnes mais
que les hommes entre eux se sont
contaminés alors situation très rare la
contagiosité est très difficile car elle
nécessite des contacts très rapproché
contrairement au virus de lamela 19
arrive forcément
alors contrairement
c'est vrai mais je crois moi je vous dis
les choses
mais
on va dire la première chose la
contamination la plus probable se fait
avec un contact avec les sécrétions
biologiques et notamment les lésions
cutanées à est donc déjà effectivement
lorsqu'une personne est contagieuse
hélas comme vous l'avez vu des véhicules
ou des pustules sur le visage on voit
que c'est par l'intermédiaire de ses
lésions cutanées que l'on peut être
contaminé la corde alors il m'a presque
quand même il persiste une inconnue à sa
voix est ce que il peut y avoir une
contamination au moment des relations
sexuelles c'est comme vous l'avez dit il
se trouve alors probablement en raison
d'une chaîne épidémique que actuellement
ça circule essentiellement et ça
concerne essentiellement des personnes
qui ont des relations homosexuelles les
hommes qui ont des relations
homosexuelles
possiblement parce que le premier cas
qui lui a été contaminé en afrique était
homosexuel et quand il est arrivé
vigilant durement ce genre de chose
quand même parce que je veux pas je veux
pas non plus que les gens alors qu'on
n'a aucune certitude se met à avoir une
image des homosexuels parce que ça va
très vite on sait que je connais le
battre et on va se dire 10 homosexuels
ne l'est pas c'est très facile alors
bien sûr en aucun cas ce à dire que les
cas humains qui ont été décrits sa
touche et les hommes et les femmes
jusqu'aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune raison
qu'il y ait qu une communauté qui est
atteinte articulaire mance et c'est
quelque chose qui circule par contre
l'épidémiologie des événements actuels
initialement semble pour le moment
d'autres plutôt concerné c'est plus en
plus de cas est ce que ça laisse des
traces c'est ce que ça laisse des
séquelles alors d'abord les images que
vous avez montré c'est la variole
humaine classique ce sont des photos
anciennes car comme ça a été dit la
variole a été éradiquée en 1979 de la
planète aujourd'hui le virus de la
variole humaines n'existent que dans
deux laboratoires aux états unis et en
russie sinon il n'existe pas la france
alors lui d'alors aujourd'hui c'est
convivial et comme on a dit si on a des
alors c'est effectivement c'est une
éruption qui alors il ya une première
phase on a de la fièvre on a un sorte de
syndrome grippal comme les acolytes mais
juste c'est eux c'est
on en chine bien ça
ouais c'est une infection comme une
grippe qui ensuite très rapidement après
apparaissent ces lésions qui commence
sur le visage puis qui s'étendent au
corps notamment sur la paume des mains
et sur la plante des pieds comment
soigner ça alors sont des lésions
cutanées donc qu'ils vont évoluer alors
c'est d'abord une rougeur puis ça gonfle
un peu ah ouais puis après ça fait une
véhicule puis une pustule et puis ça
sèche comme une croûte et ça tombe
d'accord mais donc c'est l'évolution
naturelle et vers la guérison le risque
de décès on faible là on n'a pas de on
n'a pas de séquelles de séquelles alors
cessez des visions qui touche la peau
tout ce qui touche la peau peut laisser
des traces fayolle humaine avant a
laissé des cicatrices et des cicatrices
voilà mais c'est ce et des cicatrices
bon elle est d'un point de vue
esthétique qui pourrait poser problème
si c'est sur le visage et sur 20 c'est
pas non plus la catastrophe
je vois marqué douleur me semble un
maintien oui dans la première phase
comme comme la grippe comme lac ohrid on
va avoir de la grille on va avoir de la
fièvre on peut avoir des douleurs
musculaires des myalgies comme avoir mal
à la gorge on peut avoir des ganglions
voilà ça c'est la première phase la
phase d'invasion ensuite l'allée le
virus se localise dans la peau et les
yeux commentant cette phase d'un valeur
la face d'invasion dure 4 5 jours par
contre après l'éruption cutanée le temps
entre les rougeurs et la cicatrisation
définitive peut durer trois semaines
alors essayez donc ces lésions cutanées
qui sont essentiellement contaminante et
donc à nouveau je répète le potentiel de
contamination inter humain est faible
donc il faudra s'attendre à ce qu'ils
aient une épidémie alors avec des
milliers de cas mais quand fois un
contact rapproché juste et notamment un
contact avec la peau pourquoi de plus en
plus de cas lorsque moi c'est une bonne
question il y a un volet qui a été
expliqué effectivement on voit
aujourd'hui que le l'homme va dans des
contrées de plus en plus profonde dans
la forêt et donc est à risque d'être en
contact avec des virus avec lesquels
habituellement ils n'étaient pas censés
entrer mais aussi le deuxième point qui
a été soulevée c'est la vaccination en
contre la variole humaine donc
effectivement il semble que cette
vaccination protéger au moins 85% contre
le risque de dissémination d'autres
types de variole notamment la variole du
singe et cette vaccination a été
interrompue en
1979 à la suite de la déclaration par
l'om est-ce de l'éradication de la
maladie donc ceux qui sont nés avant
1979 sont vaccinés contre la variole à
l'inversé de son décès un tr min son
parcours et il se pourrait que ceux qui
sont vaccinées soit mieux protégé même
si on ne sait pas si effectivement avec
le temps cette protection diminue ou pas
et s'il faut faire des rappels alors
juste parce que il ya y accueillir qui
m'envoie un message justement qui me dit
est ce que ça va pas être comme le com
avec un virus on s'amusait à faire des
gels à l'époque on en rigolait et on
s'est dit à prendre c'est retrouver tous
à la maison et voilà qu'on finit on
s'attendait pas du tout à nouveau vous
avez bien compris la contamination se
fait très peu probablement par voie
respiratoire à ce qu'on disait de
lakovic 19 d'emblée nous savions que la
contamination se fait par voie
respiratoire et qu'elle était
extrêmement contagieuse ici c'est pas le
cas alors malgré tout on peut pas être à
100% rassurant évidemment puisque comme
tout le monde le sait la variole dans le
passé c'était c'est ça s'appelait
d'ailleurs la petite vérole c'est une
maladie extrêmement dangereuse quand il
y avait pas la vaccination situé à peu
près 400 mille personnes par an
dans le monde c'est arrivé à la fin
enfin au début de l'ère
de après on va dire de lune de l'air
historique vers l'europe
et puis ça s'est diffusée et comme vous
le savez c'est le premier vaccin a
concerné cette maladie est donc en fait
génère qui a inventé la vaccination à
administrer elijah nerfs
c'était à la fin du xviie siècle il a
administré du pus venant d'une paysanne
qui a été contaminé par la variole de la
vache à un enfant de 8 10 ans et en lui
administrant la le cul donc contenant le
virus de la variole de la base
il a induit une immunité c'est à dire
par la suite il a sauvé il a sauvé la
vie il a admis le cdh il a administré la
variole humaine à cet enfant et l'enfant
n'a pas développé la maladie et c'est ce
vaccin là d'ailleurs qui pendant deux
siècles après à préserver toutes les
personnes vaccinées et à dans les années
60 l' oms à généraliser la vaccination
qui a permis l'éradication de la variole
humaine car et c'est ça le point
important la parole humaine n'a qu'un
réservoir humain alors qu'ici la variole
du singe un réservoir animal est donc
évidemment l'éradication est beaucoup
plus des vcs que pour nous est ce que
nos animaux domestiques peuvent être
justement contaminées en vain alors donc
je suis pas vétérinaire mais
effectivement ça a été dit tout à
l'heure non mais je me perds mon
collègue les animaux qui qui peuvent
développer la variole sont
essentiellement les écureuils les rats
la case départ les 100es
[Rires]
et les singes d'accord il n'y a pas de
description faite dans les chiens et les
chats domestiques ou les autres types
d'animaux donc c'est très peu probable
alors il ya juste une petite qui ont
même chose à considérer c'est à dire que
on sait par exemple que le virus a été
de la variole simienne a été introduit
aux états unis en 2003 et a touché des
humains à cause de l'importation de rats
géants gambie on sait aussi que il est
déjà arrivé des choses de ce type avec
les chiens de prairie qui sont quand
même qu'ils sont pas des chiens en fait
qu'ils sont des rongeurs donc ça veut
dire que il y à des espèces
pas ici il y en a c'est interdit de
photos en photo
[Rires]
je me doutais jacquet pages shopping
non mais aura toujours possible on n'a
pas de certitude sur le fait que les
rats mâles ra qui occupe dans nos égouts
laboratoire oui en avant nous il a
plusieurs millions donc c'est bien mais
c'est pas on ne sait pas rare que deux
vecteurs de cette barre mais c'est paris
c'est possible dit il
oui mais il ya aussi une autre chose
c'est que en 1960 on était 3 milliards
d'humains sur la planète aujourd'hui on
est 8 milliards d'humains sur la planète
donc les raisons de la promiscuité entre
nous et les populations d'animaux
sauvages dans les endroits où il ya une
végétation très abondante c'est aussi
lié au fait qu'on est très nombreux sur
la planète aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
qu'avant la fin de l'année
[Rires]
au train de shooter une manucure ou pas
la
french manucure la
gelée de minutes oui dr vous êtes
toujours très rassurant mais ce que là
vous n'êtes pas un tout petit peu trop
optimiste parce que la période
d'incubation cyril le disais c'est de
six à sept jours pendant cette période
on n'a pas de pustules on l'a même pas
de fièvre et mais on peut transmettre
donc là ce moment là ça va devenir
peut-être un danger mondial alors comme
comme ça a été dit la transmission se
fait avec des contacts au liquide
biologique très étroit donc en fait
c'est pas en parlant ou c'est pas en
prenant les transports en commun
maintenant bien sûr c'est ce que j'ai
dit c'est à dire que pour le moment on
ne sait pas du tout ce qu'il faut mettre
un masque ffp2 dans son slip
j'ai l'occasion d'ailleurs les préserver
mais je crois que malgré tout chaud est
rassurant c'est à dire aujourd'hui on
met en avant un certain nombre de
maladies infectieuses qui ont toujours
existé mais qui sont très rares et de
fait on peut effrayer la population ils
sont des maladies qui ont toujours
existé mais simplement elle elle
s'atténue à nouveau la grande inconnue
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi il ya une
transmission interhumaine plus important
oui et est ce que la contamination par
votre insu elle pourrait se faire ce
sont les deux inconnus apparaissent que
c'est vrai que mine de rien même si
c'est pas par voie orale et tout ça fait
faire des bisous
ils paraissent cassés se préparait
contre pascal aux chances et au sida ah
oui oui alors non ça n'a rien à voir
parce que d'abord évidemment c'est pas
les mêmes conséquences que c'est une
maladie qui va toucher la peau et comme
je l'expliqué dans la quasi totalité des
cas on n'en guérit et on en guérit
définitivement accord c'est à dire on
est immunisé et on ne peut plus leur
développer c'est quoi le pourcentage de
mortalité alors le pourcentage de
mortalité à nouveau ses feux c'est
calculé déterminer sur des petites
populations donc on peut pas le dire
parce que on va dire c'est de l'ordre de
1% sinon beaucoup c'est bien sûr énorme
s'il y avait beaucoup de cas mais non
mais parce qu'il fallait et savoir nager
essentiellement des enfants en fait les
morts par cette variole fille pour qui
ça ne touche que les enfants est ce que
parce que vous êtes vous étonné du fait
que justement il est quand même certain
nombre de cas à c'est inconséquent 40
alors que vous dites que c'est
extrêmement rare que ça puisse se
transmettre d'homme à homme est-ce que
ce virus là a pu éventuellement muté et
donc on le connaissait de paix en
passant de du singe ou alors maintenant
il se transmet c'est peut-être parce
qu'il a muté alors vous avez raison on
n'a pas toutes les données malgré tout
le virus de la variole est un virus très
stable c'est un virus à adn par herman
coronavirus l'hyper centre
c'est un virus très stable à 30 y est
d'ailleurs le vaccin qui est utilisée
c'est un vaccin qui date du xviie siècle
a évolué qui n'a pas évolué qu'à
protéger la population qui a permis
l'éradication semble donc je dirais il
faut être plutôt rassurant de ce domaine
mais à nouveau on n'a pas tous les
éléments scientifiques puisque l'on voit
tout le monde s'inquiétait oui ça nous
rappelle à chaque fois ça nous rappelle
le coroner
on est on est on est traumatisé l'année
prochaine ils vont nous dire finement et
tous dansé confinement vous serrez les
laissions ici bien sûr c'est qu'elle est
faut-il avoir peur de ce nouveau variant
est on était là en disant non mais c'est
un truc qui est loin se transmet pas
forcément avec
exactement là bas alors là si les chiens
de prairie
c'est quoi exactement est pas beaucoup
dans les prairies l'acheter plus dire
j'avais une petite maison là bas j'ai
pris beaucoup de médias parlent de cette
épidémie est ce qu'il donnerait autant
par les quelques il ya quelques années
avant le coup vitesses mécanique bien ce
que c'est une copine qui nous a
traumatisés du coup on tombe très bonne
question paranoïa qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
parlé il ya quelques années en 2017 en
2018 par exemple probablement en tout
cas il y a eu des épidémies en dehors de
l'afrique dans les années 2000
personnellement je n'en avais jamais
entendu parler donc effectivement est la
médiatisation aujourd'hui met en avant
et attire l'attention sur des
problématiques qui reste quand même tout
assez rare à nouveau c'est très
intéressant d'un point de vue médical
scientifique épidémiologique mais c'est
pas demain que vous allez attraper la
variole du singe soyez rassurés dessus
et les mêmes le risque d'attraper la
cambe 19 me paraît beaucoup plus
important moi je me souviens d'un
médecin qui disait au tout début c'est
pas parce qu'à trois chinois qui tous
bien sait plus qui croire
c'est non mais tout le monde a pris la
contamination ce menu ne se lèvera par
les airs au sol
nécessite un contact très rapprochées
très prolongée et surtout avec les
liquides biologiques donc avec les
pustules et le liquide le plus qui sort
de la peau mais on va avoir peur voilà
demain au sida les voilà bon c'est pas
pour moi mais pour voilà pour lui c'est
qu'il va lui aussi ben voilà guillaume
genton à ce qui va ce de ne pas y aller
par techart deux fois avant d'aller
embrasser une fille
je peux le rassurer il peut embrasser
tranquillement et vous encourager au
préservatif
non à nouveau aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun
argument pour laisser penser que la
contamination se fait par voie sexuelle
pas pourquoi vous disiez les deux hommes
tout à l'heure non j'ai dit que
actuellement on va dire l'épidémie
semble avoir débuté avec des hommes qui
ont des relations homosexuelles
donc c'est quoi pas nécessairement parce
que justement ils ont eu des relations
proches et donc ils ont été probablement
contaminés par la peau voilà par la peau
maintenant effectivement persiste la
question est ce que c'est la peau qui
les a contaminés ou est ce que c'est les
relations sexuelles elle même on ne sait
pas oui c'est chez désolé mais un homme
ça la même peau qu'une femme donc si
c'est entre hommes c'est bien thomas
sexuelle parce que sinon j'aurais
pourquoi les hommes homosexuels ce
contaminerait plus par la peau avec un
contact de la moria ce que l'ordinateur
ce
que je veux que la percée la musicienne
riz contaminé en afrique était
possiblement mais nouveau site une
hypothèse homosexuels pas allez donc
hélas hélas le contaminer des personnes
c'est une chaîne épidémie va sécher
d'épidémie si vous nous rejoignez on
parle de ce qui inquiète tout le monde a
bien entendu en ce moment c'est de cette
affaire la variole du singe il y à un
kaka été recensés en région parisienne
il ya un instant et c'est vrai que on
commence un peu à flipper parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas qu'il ya une
défiance 1 mais siri que l'on dit
aujourd'hui comme il ya des nouvelles
maladies qui arrive on voit là on se dit
parfois qu'on fait c'est pas une bonne
maladie ça pour le coup mais c'est vrai
qu'on se dit voilà on nous a dit la même
chose avec le sport avec le corona
sireix en a on a vécu un cauchemar oui
gibernau rendez compte docteur on
parlait de quelques cas alors etats unis
canada espagne portugal et là d'un coup
on est en train d'en parler en direct
série annonce voilà la région parisienne
un peu importe sur la région parisienne
nous voilà touchées en france on
comprenait notre inquiétude on se dit
que là on est face à une propagation
ultra rapide nous voilà déjà touché avec
le coran navires us on avait été touchée
bien longtemps après tu sais rien on se
dit regardez le presque le monde et
rouge déjà donc vous comprenez notre
inquiétude vous bien sûr je pense que
c'est un phénomène qu'il faut observer
et bien sûr analysé il faut comprendre
les chaînes de contamination et les
mécanismes par lesquels le virus se
propage comment c'est arrivé et quels
sont les moyens de près mention
évidemment il faut bien sûr développer
des travaux scientifiques de
surveillance d'ailleurs les autorités
sanitaires probablement le mettre en
place maintenant vu les modes de
contamination suspecté il narre n'est
pas on ne s'attend pas à voir une
épidémie massive avec de décontamination
en prenant le métro ou en sur le lieu de
travail ou dans un milieu
intrafamiliales à nouveau au jour
d'aujourd'hui ne sont contaminants que
les personnes malades qui y ont des
vésicules sur la pole l'éruption cutanée
sur la peau car le mode pour le moment
connue reconnue de cette contamination
et le contact avec les sécrétions
biologiques malgré tout je redis la
transmission interhumaine de ce set
vario delà est relativement difficile
mais tout ça ce sont des données qui
sont basées sur des données antérieures
au moment où effectivement c'était en
lisière déflorer donc il ya quand même
une inconnue donc je ne peux pas dire
tout va bien ne regardons pas ça mais
pour le moment c'est que quelques cas on
met le projecteur sur une maladie
infectieuse relativement rares et à mon
sens peu contagieuse mais épicé pardon
mais saisissez pas une nouvelle maladie
c'est le cas quand le coc vide est
arrivé personnes connaissaient locaux
vides 19 là c'est pas une nouvelle
maladie cette maladie il a été décrite
dans les années 60 lors d'une
contamination
d'humains qui travaillait dans un
laboratoire ou des singes étaient
captifs donc c'est une maladie connue
depuis longtemps donc c'est faux c'est
très bon relativiser voilà mais c'est
vrai le mode de contamination entre les
hommes méritent d'être explorées pour
savoir exactement quels sont les risques
pour prévenir tout juste une question
pour les enfants vu qu'ils ont la
varicelle comment concrètement on peut
faire la différence alors vous avez
raison alors je dirais c'est le
diagnostic différentiel principal alors
d'abord évidemment la varicelle est
beaucoup plus communes donc si un enfant
présente une éruption q ce culot c'est
d'abord la varicelle alors ce qui
différencie c'est que la varicelle se
passe où différentes poules c c'est à
dire sur un lieu donné par exemple le
visage vous allez avoir des lésions
d'âge différentes dont vous allez avoir
des des rougeurs des vésicules des
pustules des croûtes au même moment au
même endroit al'inverse la variole se
fait en une seule pousser donc toutes
les lésions vont évoluer dans de la même
façon et bien sûr la variole du singe à
nouveau ça n'est que quelques cas la
varicelle c'est des millions de cas ça
n'a rien à voir